Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
el 27 de marzo de 2022 el presidente del
Salvador nayib bukele declaró estado de
emergencia y suspendió las garantías
constitucionales después que se
produjeran en el país 87 asesinatos en
un fin de semana por parte de las maras
las bandas que azotan a la población
desde hace 20 años seis meses después
más de 54.000 personas han sido
detenidas algunas como resultado de una
detención arbitraria después del estado
de sitio El Salvador tiene ahora un
nuevo récord carcelario casi el 1.4% de
la población del país está actualmente
encarcelada lo que lo convierte en la
nación con la mayor tasa de
encarcelamiento del mundo nayib bukele
decidido golpear con fuerza las
pandillas una política que goza de un
amplio apoyo popular sin embargo varios
gobiernos extranjeros y la ONU critican
los numerosos excesos autoritarios del
presidente quien Pese a que la
Constitución tiene prohibida la
reelección ha decidido presentarse como
candidato A continuación el reportaje de
lujón cubilié y Matthew
[Música]
9 de la noche en San Salvador frente a
el penalito la pequeña cárcel
estas familias están esperando la
liberación de su ser querido algunos de
ellos no han abandonado la cera durante
varias semanas pendientes de la gente
que pronuncia algunos nombres cada noche
y familiares Roberto Gómez
unos momentos después
esa noche dos hombres son liberados
muy contenta de ver a mi hijo un signo
de Esperanza al que se aferran otras
familias Pues la verdad que se siente
emoción también porque uno sabe que de
un momento a otro pues va a venir su
familiar verdad
da mucha tristeza porque en realidad
nosotros vemos lo que está sucediendo
aquí a la vez no sabemos nada de cómo
están nuestros hijos allá dentro
verdad todas estas personas nos pidieron
que ocultáramos sus rostros en este
momento en El Salvador más de una de
cada 100 personas está en la cárcel
[Música]
Tomás hay su marido estaban dispuestos a
declarar abiertamente
que tiene los 18 años este empezó a
trabajar este es uniforme
su hijo trabajaba en una agencia de
telecomunicaciones fue detenido el 6 de
junio mientras instalaba cables con su
equipo no tenía antecedentes judiciales
a todo esto nos dijo que teníamos que
esperar nada más no lo dio fecha no lo
solo lo dijeron la primera audiencia Sí
ya se llevó a cabo que son seis meses
los que él tiene que estar detenido
mientras lo investigan pero el estudio
caso por caso ya no existe en la primera
comparecencia de Joel a Puerta cerrada
se estaban examinando 162 casos desde el
seis de junio a esta fecha no sabemos el
motivo causa o razón por la detención de
él suponemos que pudo haber sido por los
tatuajes tatuajes pruebas y acusación en
El Salvador desde el final de la guerra
civil en 1992 otro mal se ha apoderado
del país las maras bandas ultraviolentas
que aterrorizan a la población dos
grandes maras La MS y la 18 se disputan
el control de los barrios
lucen su pertenencia a estos grupos
Incluso en la cara fueron las maras
quienes secuestraron a la hermana menor
de Joel en 2016 desde entonces está
desaparecida y la investigación no ha
avanzado Joel solo llevaba tatuajes
artísticos
y verdad solo tiene el nombre de la mamá
aquí en el antebrazo interior es una
palmera
con sus dos hijos agarrados de la mano
que va supuestamente en un viaje a la
playa hay quienes
mismo salvadoreños decimos que bueno lo
que está haciendo el presidente Pero
porque no les han tocado a ellos 54 mil
presos en seis meses hacinados en
cárceles ya superpobladas las familias
no tienen derecho de acceso pero tienen
que proporcionar suministros ropa blanca
papel higiénico alimentos e incluso
productos de limpieza y lo peor es no
saber cómo están
eso es lo peor
porque
el miedo que a mí me da como mamá
de pasar la misma experiencia de muchas
mamás que han ido a preguntar y les han
dicho de que ellos han fallecido y que
se los entreguen una bolsa
los grupos de Derechos Humanos están
inmersos en una oleada de denuncia sobre
detenciones arbitrarias y muertes
inexplicables en las cárceles Buenos
días niña luz Mi nombre es Mario Sorto
soy abogado y notario Cuántos años tenía
Miguel Ángel iba a cumplir 37
capturaron El Seis de abril
el 6 de abril del 2022
a qué horas exactamente lo capturaron
a las cuatro de la tarde
a las cuatro A qué se dedicaba Miguel
Ángel Ortiz la ayudante de albañil Ah
muy bien
cuando él no trabajaba
cinco diez dólares ahí agarré café me
daba jabón me daba rincho era un buen
hijo con usted cómo él parecía la
presión
dice la mujer que cuando lo llevaron lo
agarraron al instante él se puso bien
mal
en los centros penales nunca le dijeron
nada ni de ahí que no podía andar
ninguna información que era prohibido y
que el presidente les había dicho que no
lo dieran nada la siguiente semana
fuimos con la mujer apenas de mariona
por ir a veces queda sentía qué alegría
de estar ahí cerca
Pero más bien lo peor que él ya no
estaba ahí adentro ya no está ya no se
encontraba en el penal no ya estaba en
medicina legal
murió el 4 de mayo y le avisaron el 15
de mayo O sea que
prácticamente once días después y no le
informó ni centros penales ni medicina
legal sino que lo hizo la funeraria sí
como el hijo de luz decenas de detenidos
han muerto en circunstancias
inexplicables y sin atención médica el
presidente nayib bukele usa el odio
hacia esos detenidos para aumentar su
popularidad
todas las celdas estarán cerradas las 24
horas del día nadie saldrá ni siquiera
al patio no verán más la luz del día en
los últimos cinco años la delincuencia
ha disminuido drásticamente pero se
calcula que hay unos 70.000 miembros de
maras en el país un tatuaje con las
letras MS o el número 18 como en Este
joven es la promesa de una larga condena
en prisión
si nosotros ahorita lo vamos a llevar a
lo que es la delegación de soyapango
este va a ir a consultar en el sistema
verdad A ver si él posee una ficha ya
como pandillero activo y posiblemente
quede detenido por el delito de
agrupación lícitas y respetamos la
autoridad al gobierno
bendecimos al gobierno bendecimos la
autoridad porque lo que ustedes hacen es
lo correcto pero ante nosotros estamos
sometidos a Dios Él es mi hijo y él es
también trabajador que congrega conmigo
en la iglesia evangélica apostólica
deteniendo a su hijo
No sabría decirle porque la verdad de la
cuadra aquí Dios tiene la última palabra
verdad
el estado de excepción vigente desde
finales de marzo permite a la policía no
informar a los sospechosos del motivo de
su detención
la verdad de las cosas es que luego era
esto
Dios sabe cómo lleva toda usted sabía
que su hijo era pandillero lo fue hace
años ahorita no Ahorita él está ha
estado prácticamente en las manos de
Dios pues me dijo
son los corresponden a renta por parte
de los pandilleros
ahí están
simples sospechas denuncias de un vecino
primero arrestan luego investigan
tienen para estar tomando tienen todo
aquí entonces y Quién trabaja aquí
como le estoy explicando
a él él ahorita se ha quedado sin
trabajo pero si trabaja yo recibo ayuda
de papá de mi hija yo eso le estoy
explicando a él
no yo eso le estoy explicando yo a él
porque
no pero es que él no es pandillero yo
como le dije a él sí
pero Ajá pero no es porque sea
pandilleros la verdad hay que buscar
bien el teléfono es que lo ha de haber
votado quebrado
Cómo no va a tener
los niños
al registrar el teléfono de la esposa
del joven el policía encuentra una foto
comprometedora
el policía no nos la muestra pero dice
que en ella está haciendo una seña con
la mano distintiva de las maras las dos
personas son finalmente detenidas una
gran que alivia a la gran mayoría de los
salvadoreños pero que se lleva todo a su
paso
Ernesto es uno de los 15.000
funcionarios despedidos recientemente
vivió los dos primeros meses del estado
de emergencia en la policía
era una cacería a lo que cayera verdad y
pidieron cuotas eso es cierto todas las
unidades les pidieron todas las unidades
policiales la unidad pequeña que era el
puesto policial que era más pequeño está
la delegación todo Usted tiene que
cumplir una meta hubo un día creo que
fue el miércoles pasado se capturaron
mil noventas pandilleros en un día ahora
están oyendo se esconden como ratas y
cuando yo como ratas no es por ofender a
las ratas sino que literalmente se
esconden en hoyos en la tierra
en primer lugar se veía como algo
beneficioso porque el policía en el
accionar contra las pandillas estaba
amarrado de las manos
Pero luego se ve que llevaba una
connotación de otro tipo verdad quiere
agarrar al que al que cayera y ahí se
han cometido mucha injusticia porque se
ha tenido gente que no tiene nada que
ver con pandilla y lo que pasaba que los
pandilleros al ver esta situación de de
represión contra él porque han hecho
Buscar mecanismos de irse de sus lugares
verdad refugiarse en los cerros qué
Pobrecitos que le estaba violando sus
derechos humanos
las ongs
las organizaciones
internacionales defensoras del crimen
porque ellos dicen que defienden los
Derechos Humanos Pero es mentira
Cuántas familias en nuestro país no
tienen una historia que contar
de terror
de lo que les han causado las pandillas
[Música]
en nuestro país y vamos a conocer hasta
gente bella A ver qué nos cuenta a ver
qué nos trae Así que vamos a iniciar por
acá
reunión de las juventudes de nuevas
ideas el partido del presidente nayib
bukele el presidente bukele ha sido un
ejemplo para todos los jóvenes
salvadoreños inspirados por el
presidente más joven de latinoamérica y
que va a seguir haciendo historia para
el 2024 gracias
2024 el año de las próximas elecciones
presidenciales la Constitución
salvadoreña prohíbe formalmente la
reelección pero nayib bukele decidió
ignorarlo
miedo de que vinieran por ellos por
expresarse por hablar mal del presidente
o cosas así Qué opinan de eso
actualmente actualmente la gente tiene
miedo de expresarse porque tienen miedo
a que el gobierno venga por ellos qué
opinas tú
de esto perdón pero eso de que
actualmente si no no
más de 3000 quejas por detenciones
arbitrarias más de 80 muertos en ámbito
carcelario este o sea si se está
denunciando otras violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos Durante este estado de
excepción bueno pienso que el presidente
fue muy claro en su discurso en la ONU
recientemente
somos un estado libre y soberano y todo
país o todo organismo internacional
independientemente sea cual sea su
postura de verdad si viene algo negativo
un comentario negativo Porque pienso que
está un poco de más
un discurso alineado con el de un
presidente convencido el estado de
excepción está diseñado para responder a
una emergencia de seguridad pero después
de seis meses se está prolongando para
algunos libera el país de las maras para
otros lo somete a otro tipo de violencia
la de los excesos autoritarios del
estado
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]